welcome back to las vegas now millions
of people live
every day with severe pain it doesn't
matter if you start hurting today or
if you're dealing with an injury from 30
years ago dr
devin at spinal care of nevada and his
gentle method of
chiropractic care can help
[Music]
when my back gets out of alignment it
pinches nerves
and nerve pain is pretty awful you
are just mentally exhausted from
this pain that just seems to go
like this all day long
and at times i cry sometimes it's a
lifetime of wear and tear we have old
accidents falls injuries we think
nothing about
what they catch up to us down the road i
came in and i was literally hobbling in
the door
you know i was bent over i couldn't even
stand up straight my wife
faye oh it's been probably now eight
months ago
she started developing uh tiredness
fatigue
she had headaches she had nausea started
getting some adjustments
and probably after about three to four
weeks she started feeling a little bit
better
noticeably so and in about two months
magically so to speak she was fine
danuka chiropractic
is a more gentle style of chiropractic
the the gentle approach avoids the the
twisting the cracking
or the manipulation um and our patients
just prefer that
we can treat a wide range of patients
young children
people who've been in bad car accidents
bad falls maybe we've even
had surgery before up to 80 90 year old
men and women with
severe osteoporosis and arthritis so
really one of the keys to our success
is our two day work up day one we're
going to sit down
and i'm going to listen to our patients
and i mean truly listen we'll run a
series of tests checking
every range of motion of their spine
orthopedic neurological test
posture and then we're going to take
digital
opposing view x-rays these are some of
the best type of films in our field
i'm going to study those i'm going to
study the notes so day two
we're going to sit down and i'm going to
go over the findings and listen if i
can't help someone
i'm going to let them know and i'm going
to get them to the right doc if i can
help i'm very straightforward
how long is it going to take what's it
going to cost what's my insurance do or
not do
because if you're anything like me you
don't want financial surprises and we're
going to get to work
and start getting some relief as soon as
possible my life's changed immensely
i'm pain-free where i used to have
shoulder neck pain i wasn't able to lift
my arms
brush my own hair it's almost like a
relief
when he adjusts i can feel it
like that it's it's amazing normally
that two-day workup is 180
what we're going to do for viewers of
the show is give it to the first
20 callers i have to limit it after that
it goes up to regular price for only 37
you heard dr devin the first 20 callers
will only pay
37 for both normally it's 180
call 702 566 hope or 4673
you can also get more information at
drdevin.com